hemos hablado mucho de demandan así que
ahora hablaremos de la oferta y usaré
uvas como ejemplo supongamos que somos
agricultores de uva los mejores de la
región así que bueno te introduciremos y
lo haré en color morado porque en una
hora las uvas tú sabes así que te
introduzco a la ley de la oferta tras la
cual como ley de la demanda como la ley
de la demanda hace mucho sentido
intuitivo y ahorita mantendremos todo
equivalente pero después cambiaremos de
rumbo si mantenemos todo igual y lo
único que hacemos es cambiar el precio
entonces la ley de la oferta lo que nos
dice es si el precio aumenta y voy a
poner aquí p
abreviando presión si el precio aumenta
entonces la oferta de hecho debo tener
cuidado porque es la cantidad ofrecida a
la cantidad ofrecida sube y ya con esto
ya con esto tú qué crees que sigue aquí
exacto si el precio baja la cantidad
ofrecida también baja y bueno tú debes
aquí notar que yo pongo cantidad
ofrecida y cantidad ofrecida y esto es
justo como vimos con demanda cuando
hablamos de demanda
o bajando hablamos de toda la relación
de cantidad de precio cambiante y el
otro lado cuando hablamos de una
cantidad particular demandada decimos
cantidad demandada no solamente decimos
demanda y es exactamente igual para la
oferta en cantidad particular tendríamos
cuidado de decir cantidad y si hablamos
de aumento en oferta hablamos de toda la
relación de precio cambiando ya sea que
suba o que baje así que hay que
asegurarnos de que todo esto hace total
sentido para nosotros y creo que
intuitivamente lo hace pensemos en
nosotros como grandes agricultores y ya
lo había dicho antes somos los mejores y
bueno pondré que una tabla de oferta
programa de oferta de uva que es en
realidad una tabla que muestra la
relación entre todo lo demás igual el
precio y la cantidad ofrecida entonces
vamos a etiquetar algunos casos justo
como hicimos con la demanda casos aquí y
casos y por acá yo pongo precios donde
estamos tomando en precios precios por
kilo y acá tenemos la cantidad producida
a través del transcurso de un periodo de
tiempo cuando hacemos cualquiera de
estos programas de off
el programa de demanda estamos tomando
los datos con respecto a un período de
tiempo particular puede ser un día un
mes incluso por un año pero esa es la
única manera de hacer sentido de saber
cuál es la cantidad y bueno que será
producida la cantidad producida si se
toma un dicho precio y acá yo voy a
poner cantidad ofrecida entonces digamos
que el caso 1 vamos a tomar el caso 1 si
el precio de las uvas y el precio de las
uvas por kilo es de 50 centavos el kilo
de 50 centavos el kilo de bueno de hecho
de hecho dejarán deja luego de esta otra
manera haré con números enteros entonces
si el precio de las uvas por kilo es de
1 dólar digamos que para nosotros eso es
un precio relativamente bajo así que
solamente usaremos nuestra tierra más
sencilla la más fértil donde es fácil
producir uvas entonces es más fértil la
más barata donde nadie más quiere
sembrar ahí nadie más la quiero salvar
otras cosas es solamente buena para uvas
entonces nosotros vamos a proporcionar y
bueno de aquí es aquí es precios por
kilo precio por kilo precio por kilo y
supongamos que en ese año se produjeron
mil kilos bueno jamás he sido una
agricultura de uva y no sé si sea
razonable esa cantidad pero supongamos
que que en ese año fueron 1000 kilos y
también tenemos ahora el caso 2 donde
supongamos que el precio subió a 2
dólares y ahora no solamente vamos a
querer producir lo mismo sino que vamos
a querer comprar más tierra tierra que
quizás tenga otros usos también quizás
tierra que no sea tan productiva para
para uvas quién sabe pero si compraremos
tierra porque queremos ahora más
producción de uvas entonces quizás ahora
estamos dispuestos a producir lo que son
supongamos que 2000 kilos lo escribo dos
mil dos mil kilos y podemos seguir con
ésta con la misma dinámica supongamos
que ahora el precio si en el caso 3 el
precio fuera de tres dólares por el kilo
por cada kilo porque ahora quizás
queremos producir más uvas queremos tal
vez estamos dispuestos a trabajar un
poco más
o plantar cosas más cercanas a otras y
bueno cosas así sembrar no sé como
siempre no no soy agricultor y ahora
supongamos que en el caso 3 no sé 2500
kilos es lo que obtenemos y haré un caso
más bueno supongamos que en el caso 4 el
precio sube a 4 dólares el kilo y la
misma dinámica dejar de plantar otras
cosas usar esas tierras para las uvas
porque ahora las uvas me están dando más
producción y supongamos que en el caso 4
yo voy a producir 2 mil 750 kilos y
ahora podemos dibujar una curva de la
oferta así como dibujamos la curva de la
demanda lo haré y es exactamente
exactamente lo mismo
pondremos el precio en el eje vertical y
bueno no soy muy fan de eso porque como
puedes ver tendemos a hablar de precios
en variable independiente y en la mayor
parte de matemáticas y ciencia ponemos
la variable independiente en el eje
horizontal pero la convención en
economía es ponerlo en el eje vertical y
bueno aquí tenemos también precios
precios por kilo y ahora vayamos con lo
que es el eje horizontal
entonces vamos a poner aquí los datos
que corresponden a la cantidad cantidad
ofrecida y bueno lo tomaré para el año
siguiente estamos estamos asumiendo que
todo esto es para el próximo año donde
esta información está en miles de kilos
así que lo voy a poner miles de kilos y
veamos nos vamos de 2.000 a cerca de
3000 así que esto va a ser uno
representando 1001 mil 22 mil sigue tres
mil y después los precios se van desde
el 1 al 4 así que 1 2 3 4
4 entonces bueno podemos graficar estos
puntos estos son puntos específicos en
la curva de la oferta entonces en un
dólar tendríamos la oferta de 1000 en un
dólar mil kilos eso es en el en el caso
uno en dos dólares tendríamos la oferta
de lo que es dos mil kilos dos mil kilos
es el caso 2 ahora en el caso 3 tenemos
3 dólares está la oferta en 2 mil 500
kilos
aquí estoy mal saben cómo confundo mis
ejes así no funciona para mí este es el
eje donde vemos las cosas que están
cambiando
aquí no siempre se maneja así pero bueno
ahora entonces tenemos un dólar 1000
kilos que está justamente aquí dos
dólares dos mil kilos que está
justamente aquí y aquí aquí no acá no
son los precios acá son los precios así
que tres dólares dos mil 500 kilos que
es justamente más o menos por aquí bueno
de hecho lo voy a hacer el mismo color
en el mismo color azul para no
confundirnos entonces tres dólares dos
mil 500 kilos está más o menos
y eso es el caso 3 ahora el caso 4 de
hecho debo ser clara porque se están
acercando bastante así que bueno 2500
kilos es más o menos por aquí más o
menos por aquí ese es el caso 3 ahora el
caso 4 en 4 dólares 2.750 es
aproximadamente más o menos por aquí eso
es el caso 4 y si los conectamos
entonces todos estarán en nuestra curva
de la oferta que está más o menos la voy
a pintar está la curva de la oferta más
o menos así ajá algo así se pinta y
bueno también hay un un precio mínimo
que manejamos que es en el que se inició
vendiendo las uvas supongamos que está
más o menos por aquí y ya ha conectado a
la curva así y así es como se miraría
nuestra curva de la oferta y recordemos
que lo único que estamos variando aquí
es el precio entonces si el precio
cambiará y todo lo demás se quedará
igual fijo nos moveríamos a través de
esta curva y bueno en el próximo vídeo
hablaré de lo que hemos está
dejando igual fijo y que harían en
cualquier precio dado a esta curva o en
general oa toda la curva de la oferta
nos vemos